at 9am they're hard at work at the
Hungarian factory of German fan and
motor manufacturer seal abeg here they
produce status an important component of
electric motors wages here are still
lower than in Germany making hungry and
attractive production location the state
as a pact straight away today 33 pallets
are being sent to Germany they need to
get to the plot there within 24 hours
yeah Travis Coonan the trucks can drive
all the way to their destination without
customs inspections good fahren be soon
see Lord colleagues there can start
unloading them right away truck driver
George Kish needs just one document to
get his car go to Germany that's thanks
to the Schengen Agreement which allows
for the free movement of goods and
people within much of the EU
at 11am goods with a market value of
over a hundred thousand euro set off on
their journey to the German production
site the trucker has eight hundred and
sixty kilometres of highway and three
borders to cross the first is the border
between Hungary and Slovenia last summer
the influx of refugees often led to long
delays here but no migrants are choosing
alternate routes the Slovenian Hungarian
border no problem and at the border
crossing between Slovenia and Austria
Kish can just drive on through at 3pm
the trucker takes a break he's made good
time and as usual has a bite to eat at
this rest stop today it's potato
dumplings prepared by his wife he says
nothing throws his schedule off more
than chaos at the border crossings oh my
god co miata the refugee crisis
absolutely must be solved otherwise
there will always be insecurity about
whether the borders will stay open or
not Shrek Fox India at 6pm he reaches
the Austrian German border near Paso
traffic congestion has increased tens of
millions of trucks cross into Germany
every year up ahead Germany's federal
police conduct random passport checks
they're looking for people smugglers and
migrants Kish has been delayed half an
hour by the time he makes it through the
checkpoint
still he can't complain some truckers
have to wait here for hours he has a
barrel I got caught up in the traffic
jam at the border I had to wait a long
time and I couldn't take my break he's
so I've already broken a rule just to be
a little shanial you sometimes the
lineups stretch four kilometers and we
stand here for hours that cost us time
and most of all money it's now nine p.m.
and George Kish does a few stretches
before calling you tonight take the 50
guard by under German law truckers must
have nine hours of rest today at noon
the next day the truck arrives at seal
our bigs plant in southern Germany right
on schedule still management fears the
refugee crisis could jeopardize their
production deadlines are already tight
so there's no time for delays it's
pasanda lifting lost or Eastern Europe
functions as an extended workbench for
Germany many German industrial firms
produce in south southeast and Eastern
Europe and all that would be threatened
because the logistics chain would be too
long and too costly then they'd be sure
to move production back to Germany
you're not for chump owned firms would
have to start warehousing their
inventory again at great expense a day
of storage here costs about a hundred
and twenty thousand euros we can if I
try different great are three days of
storage are already 360 thousand euros
10 days would be 1.2 million that's why
this Kanban link to our external
supplies is vital keeping inventory low
is priority number one
the parts from Hungary are wheeled
straight to the assembly line and
installed within a matter of hours
this production and transport system
makes companies like seal avek
competitive